the pdb
archive is a repository of atomic
coordinates and other information
describing proteins
and other important biological
macromolecules
structural biologists use methods such
as x-ray crystallography
nmr spectroscopy and cryo-electron
microscopy to determine the location of
each atom relative to each other in the
molecule
they then deposit this information which
is then annotated and publicly released
into the archive by the wwpdb
the constantly growing pdb is a
reflection of the research that is
happening in laboratories across the
world
structures are available for many of the
proteins and nucleic acids involved in
the central processes of life
so you can go to the pdb archive to find
structures for ribosomes oncogenes
drug targets and even whole viruses
you can access the pdb database freely
online
at by www.rcsb.org
it will bring you to this main page the
main page usually has featured proteins
molecules of the month
and it's quite interesting to read some
of these featured proteins
but for the purpose of this tutorial
we'll be talking to you about lysozyme
and lysozyme as a hydrolase
a ubiquitous protein found in many
different organisms and crosses various
levels of taxonomy
if you look at the side here you will
see that there are many different
structures that are published online
and you can see references to the
articles that basically shows where
these structures were first published
you can also see that there is a huge
number of pages of lysozyme structures
note that all of the structures that are
in the protein data bank
are classified by a four-letter code
in this example we are going to focus on
the crystal structure of the native
human lysozyme
the code for this protein is one rex
you can search them by their code easily
if you have that on hand
the structure for one rex was determined
by x-ray diffraction with the resolution
of at 1.5 angstrom
the lower the numeric values of
resolution mean the better the
resolution
if you click into the link you can see
the original citation here
the authors and the link to the original
paper in pubmed
if you want to define the sequence of
this structure you could look here under
the sequence tab
you can see here the sequence of amino
acids as well as the contributions of
those amino acids to secondary structure
here is an alpha helix and here is a
beta sheet
if you just wanted the plain amino acid
sequence in plain text format
you can go to display files and then
fast a sequence
here is the sequential order of amino
acids from the n-terminus to the
c-terminus
you can also go to the 3d view here is a
cartoon version that is displayed
you can change the color setting to
sequence id and you will see the ribbon
color changes from blue to red color
similar to the rainbow colors the blue
color indicates the in terminal
and the red colors indicate c terminal
if you change the color to secondary
structure you can see the alpha helixes
the beta sheets and the random coil of
the protein
if you want to take a look at the pdb
file you can just display it
and it's a text file it contains all the
atomic coordinates of every atom
each pdb file begins with the
description of the molecule
credits to the authors that solve the
structure
and experimental details of the analysis
[Music]
next the file lists the amino acid
sequence of the protein
[Music]
part of the pdb file defines the precise
position of each atom of the structure
in three-dimensional space
each atom is described in a separate
line
the first few columns define the atom as
part of a particular amino acid in the
sequence
later columns list a set of x y and z
coordinates to precisely locate the atom
in the structure
[Music]
you